i love you guys so much and i'm so happy
to see both of you
i know it's so good to see you nice to
see you i know jenny the last time you
were on the show you were pregnant
yes i was like i hadn't told anyone i
was pregnant i was very pregnant that i
had like the zoom camera right here by
my face
because i didn't want anyone to see what
was underneath but i think like my face
was taking up like the whole computer
thank you for doing that again
and how is your daughter doing
uh the baby's wonderful
she's uh i think she's a really nice
person you're gonna keep her i think so
[Applause]
um and charlie i'm so excited to see you
um charlie and i did a movie together
back in the day called going the
distance it was a romantic comedy and it
was just really fun and we had the best
time making it
oh my god it's so much fun and that was
my first studio movie i was ever in um
so i was convinced that i was going to
get fired the whole time
i was it was about halfway through that
i was like i think they have to keep me
at this point i think it's too much to
re-shoot
yeah and we like had fun like we partied
off the set too which was so much fun i
have a story that i told uh on justin's
podcast but
it deserves retelling because there was
an actress who we were all hanging out
in your hotel room and she said to you
she said drew do you want to have a
punching contest with me oh yeah
yeah and i remember thinking oh man this
girl is going to lose so bad
and so she and you were like yeah sure
go ahead you go first
so the girl's like okay cool and she
punches your arm and you're like okay no
i'll go
and you hit this girl's arm and there
was like a thunderous crack i feel like
you set the like alarm off
and
it within five seconds there was a
bruise on her arm that looked like the
continent in africa and she was like i
guess you win
that was my fondest memory of doing that
[Applause]
and i'm lucky enough to say that your
wife and i played um besties and
neighbors on santa clarita diet mary
elizabeth it's just one of my favorite
people ever and i love your wife so much
and you're both with people i'm single
but i'm really excited i love
valentine's day i can't help it which
now i just let the cat out of the bag
about my opinion of it i want to know
your opinions on on valentine's day
please if you will well i love it i love
it which doesn't mean that it hasn't
occasionally
really burned me um but i really i
really really love romance which also
means that sometimes you have to be open
to um
to do a sting of sorts but yes
it scared me at a young age because
you're in school and everyone's passing
the notes and you're like am i going to
get a note that goes like right by your
desk it's like everything's going to
mitch or johnny and i wasn't getting
anything like that oh man mitch and then
you know they're doing a little finger
thing where it's like you have a freckly
face okay thanks
jenny did you get like an odd
weird valentine's day present one time
yes i did
that is like a little weird tell me
about it please
it was truly the worst so my boyfriend
at the time gave me
he was like happy valentine's day and
gave me his digital camera that he had
taken many photos with um
and he put it in a sock and he gave it
to me as a present and then our activity
that we were going to do that day on
valentine's day was that we went to go
buy him a new camera
it's the worst
the worst present anyone
note to self no socks for mary elizabeth
yeah exactly
um well i've watched the movie and i
absolutely loved it and i loved how hard
you stick the landing and everyone in
our audience is going to get a link to
the movie and they're going to watch it
after
which is so exciting so we can just
celebrate you through and through what
is it that like spoke to you
specifically
or you hope people take away from this
because there is a lot to take away
i mean for me it started with the
writing i i read this script i couldn't
put it down
it was such a sweet story but it was so
well crafted i was laughing out loud and
i was really invested in the characters
and to me it was just one of the better
scraps that i've been said yeah yeah i
felt i felt the same way and
what really was happening in this script
is that you root for the romance between
the two people who are looking for love
you root for it before they know to root
for it for themselves and
um i just thought man it seems so nice
to play someone who's um
who's looking for love and doesn't know
how to find it because um
that is a that is a classic journey and
it was just in there so beautifully
well and that is what i'm talking about
and that is so helpful
[Music]
you